number of children living in conflict
zones has doubled since the end of the
Cold War and are translating enough that
means a new report by the charity saved
the children that one in five youngsters
around the globe live in areas affected
by armed conflict
[Music]
Alitalia viva la control over mother who
correct as I had to or yet
[Music]
inaho Saran daddy I am NOT my mother
initially the other nurse very limited
[Music]
we cool
dad that is all had Joanna Krupa's the
sorrowful tell again another and it was
and Omega Vianney shall be a fear Nene
[Music]
honey
the Harton hurt me
some 420 million children live in
conflict zones at least a thousand days
resolved every year since 2010 the
number of recorded cases of rights
violations against children has almost
tripled that includes cases of killing
maiming abduction and sexual violence
the increase comes despite many of the
world's most powerful figures
campaigning for the protection of young
people in war zones forces continue
their advance bearing down on the city
of Benghazi home to nearly 700,000 men
women and children prevent images of
emaciated children how many more
children have to die the horrific
humanitarian disaster that is killing
tens and tens of thousands of
defenseless children
the death of children the destruction of
hospitals all that is a massacre which
needs to be condemned
our report today shows that right now
almost one in five children on the
planet are living in conflict zones
that's more than at any time in the last
two decades not only that but the
consequences of living in these war
zones are catastrophic we estimate that
around 300 babies are dying due to the
consequences of war every single day
well in 2017 420 million children
worldwide were living in areas affected
by conflict that was an increase of 30
million on the previous year so what
this is is part of a really disturbing
global trend where more and more
children are being caught up in conflict
the international systems that ensure
accountability are breaking down so that
when when people commit crimes against
children they know they can get away
with it so what we're calling on is for
the government to stand up for children
in war zones and ensure that when people
do perpetrate crimes against children
they're held to account what we're
really calling for today is for the UK
government to update its protection of
civilians in conflict strategy first of
all the UK government needs to ensure
that children at the heart of all of
their defense diplomacy and aid and then
they need to use their seat at some of
the most powerful tables in the world at
the UN
to ensure that other countries policy
and on the most dangerous countries for
children the report identifies
Afghanistan Iraq Syria and Yemen as
being those well labelled peace nominee
and peace activist Cathy Kelly told us
the international community needs to do
so much more to safeguard young people
and stop the wars this children
certainly can't be held accountable for
their governments but whether it's
military because of countries could work
[Music]
much more effectively so we have to take
responsibility ourselves and then
encourage other people to do likewise
they must do everything they can to stop
this war and just
you